schon wieder ein missbrauchsfall und
schon wieder in nordrhein westfalen ein
38 jähriger familienvater aus solingen
soll seine eigene tochter missbraucht
haben
bild reporter scheelite schalker steht
vor dem haus des tatverdächtigen in
solingen uns mir nun live zugeschaltet
was genau ist bei diesem missbrauchsfall
in nordrhein-westfalen in solingen
passiert wäre es macht immer wieder
sprachlos man hat in den letzten tagen
den eindruck dass die nachrichten nicht
nachlassen und jedes mal ist es immer
wieder ein ein schreckliches eine
schreckliche tat die uns auch als
journalistin hier ja fast schon
sprachlos macht in solingen entsteht ein
38-jähriger mann im verdacht seine
mittlerweile 12 jährige tochter sexuell
missbraucht zu haben
und er wird auch verdächtigt
kinderpornografisches material besessen
zu haben
das hat heute die staatsanwaltschaft
wuppertal bekannt gegeben ausgelöst
waren die ermittlungen durch durch
erkenntnisse des bundeskriminalamtes im
letzten jahr vom oktober letzten jahres
dort wurde im darknet das foto entdeckt
und weitere ermittlungen führten dann
schon im letzten jahr hier zu diesem man
hier in solingen man konnte das kind
identisch wären das auf dem foto zu
erkennen ist und weitere ermittlungen
haben dann ergeben auch die auch durch
sicherstellungen der laptops und
datenträger des mannes haben jetzt
ergeben dass er richtig ist und im
verdacht steht seine tochter sexuell
missbraucht
wir und wo kam es dann jetzt zu der
verhaftung des mannes
einige kilometer entfernt in rösrath
wurde der mann gemeinsam mit den beiden
kindern er hat die tochter die jetzt
zwölf ist und ein sohn der neun jahre
alt ist und mit der mutter der kinder
wurden sie auf einem campingplatz man
muss dazu leider sagen ein fkk
campingplatz
das gibt der ganzen sache auch noch mal
ein ganz ganz bösen beigeschmack auf dem
campingplatz wurde der mann gefunden
seit gestern nacht laufen dort die
ermittlungen der stellplatz wurde
angehoben die steine wurde der
campingwagen draufsteht wurden sogar in
angehoben mit hilfe der feuerwehr um
dort auch beweismaterial zu finden im
frau wurde ebenfalls festgenommen sie es
inzwischen freigelassen worden
der mann der erwartet gerade darauf dem
haftrichter vorgeführt zu werden
vielen dank starker aus solingen